uh I'm sure that if you were in that
photo and then it got leaked you'd be
like oh [ __ ] right like that would suck
like there'd be like a lot of dignity
that just got like ripped away from you
right but then not if you got the good
titties
[Music]
you're from Wisconsin yeah yeah
why'd you say it like that because I am
oh that's nice okay never going back why
not oh she don't like the cheese there
that's why Wisconsin no I actually love
Wisconsin Wisconsin is never going back
to not usually associated with love what
do you love about Wisconsin the Chiefs
the people are just so different I don't
know how to explain it are they just
nicer yeah yeah people are really really
nice they're really weird
um what do you mean by weird yeah what
do you mean I don't know just kind of
just they eat their toenails probably
really yeah we make our own fun but if I
meet someone and they're like I'm from
Wisconsin
weird or are you like I mean I have a
little bit of La drift in there but
definitely got the rules who who are
your borders and then are there any
Blended areas where like you're kind of
like decoding or like
aren't they all kind of whack then yeah
we're all kind of weird it's Midwest but
there's Chicago is that the biggest city
there yeah Chicago was like an hour for
me
um Chicago's like the biggest thing no
that's in Illinois the biggest thing
that's not in Wisconsin that's their
pride and joy you know there's a
Wisconsin volleyball team
um that uh recently decided to take some
some nudes in the locker room don't do
that with your face when you say like
how old are you I gotta get all gray
Poupon about it yeah say that sentence
again without doing that face okay
Wisconsin this is a senior citizen group
or college I want you to senior citizen
imagine senior citizen volleyball team
Wisconsin senior citizen volleyball team
uh took some news
um no it's not senior citizen get that
image out of your head it's a college
team oh oh it took some dudes in the
locker room and then their photos got
leaked online leaked oh no leaked it the
university did that happen you take a
photo and it gets leaked they so one of
the girls leaked their own photos yeah
you leaked it and things we can't show
them online because we don't want to get
taken off but Ryan did such a great
research job and sent me the photo so
all of us can look at them over here if
you guys want to look at them over here
this is them right here they are group
photos wow right everybody take a look
at the facial expressions we've got
going on this is the real news [ __ ]
we've got a holy why is there numbers on
there that's their Journey that's a show
their jersey number we're not this is
strictly for news research in order to
accurately can we put them on the green
screen in the background why why why did
they take the group new because they
want to have fun too yo it's like guys
in the guidebook I mean we would have
done it with our dicks out yeah bro we
had cell phone cameras come on I see
that's like sports culture then I guess
it is college and college happens to be
like the most uh that makes the most
sense for that group and that age to do
something like this exploring or
ratchetness yeah like that and senior
citizens for sure Bart yeah comes full
circle all right that's also the
generation that should know better like
in terms of tech leaking like that's
kind of easy who leaked it yeah back in
the day somebody would have to take like
a [ __ ] Kodak flash Photography they
would have to develop it and then send
it to the newspaper outlets and stuff
like that and then after like three days
of press it would get put out I'm just
thinking what college is doing more
research it's Wisconsin do you think the
person that was taking the picture was
coach and she also had her boobs to show
support so she did it
it's on be real because it's the front
and the back but be real
they're like oh no we're all naked it's
be real we have to be real right now
that's how they walk around just their
tops are still on it's just exposing the
breast specific I like the idea because
it was two photos that they only showed
hers so yeah this is for the University
of Wisconsin
um they said in a statement that the
UW-Madison Police Department is
investigating multiple crimes after
private photo and videos of members
there's video can you find the video
around a video of members of the women's
volleyball team were shared on the
internet videos smoking me man yeah dude
we are aware that private photos and
video of UW volleyball student athletes
that were never intended to be shared
publicly are being circulated digitally
is that UW yeah UW dub it's a big school
yeah but what's the great anecdote
what's the takeaway Ryan what happened
at the following game so after this like
whole thing broke out
um the next the next game that they
played had the uh big record for the
most attendees for NCAA
wow it works that's the bottle marketing
Works marketing wow watch the WNBA start
doing this too it becomes a thing
hey you speaking of the WNBA you know
what uh Shaq there was a video of a
shack going around talking about the
WNBA he goes and this just made me think
of Steve he goes the WNBA they have all
the pieces to have a really good League
they have Shooters they have ball
handlers they have finesse but there's
no dunks he goes if they just lower the
rim a little bit
we put butts in the seat I don't think
that's the problem that's what Shaq said
he's a basketball player he knows he's
thinking basketball
he's not thinking why people want to
watch [ __ ] oh so what do you do if
you're a press if you're Bart silver of
the W how do you solve the problem
you're a jiu jitsu guy right yeah yeah
and you look at all like women sujitsu
like the good thing is women should it's
actually popping but like let's say it
wasn't from a jiu jitsu lens you'd
probably be like oh yeah if there's fork
and more arm breaks people are gonna
watch it more no if they're doing Jiu
Jitsu naked the more people watch it you
know I didn't say that Anthony did but
the record
what the [ __ ] Anthony didn't they test
that with the football with the bikini
football Powderpuff lingerie football
and stuff yeah and you know what every
single time I pass by that on the
channel I let it stay a little bit
longer yeah a little bit longer but then
we'll change it I I think it's the Bill
Burr then I'm disgusted the billboard
theory is the best it's if every woman
that was a feminist went to a [ __ ]
women's game they would sell out that's
true but they don't go they don't show
up they don't go so who's fault is it
but they will complain about the pay Gap
but they're not going to go to the game
go support yeah make your own [ __ ]
that's what fills the pay Gap is ticket
sales but they're not lying the same
argument with like the whole like Asian
content in Hollywood too it's like if
you're complaining there's not enough
roles are you going to every single
Asian release right exactly yeah because
well you know a guy that would buy
multiple tickets
that movie Just for supporting yeah
instead of 1C he just buys like five
seats that's what that's what a what's
it called gold open does
um what's gold open it's it's a it's
like a coalition of entertainment people
that they uh will buy out a theater when
an Asian movie comes on oh yeah and then
they'll read and it's empty but they'll
respond well they'll reissue the tickets
to people to come support it and they'll
be like we'll buy the tickets then so
that way the record goes up on like hey
it was a smash uh hit weekend but yeah
gold open is a good job at the end and
also uh remember ratesh said the same
thing about how Indian people go to them
they're like how come you're not in
Avengers or some [ __ ] and he's like have
are you even watching the ones I am in
yeah yeah yeah yeah I Gotta Be You gotta
be watching that for me to get that eye
it must be annoying to hear or how they
can go this route but I do like that I
do like the blueprint the blueprint to
NCAA record cells is out so people could
follow it no yep I think I think people
need to follow in the footsteps of Kim
Kardashian and and Paris Hilton and have
a sex page so
back page and then just see what happens
after that we don't know we'll just
magic will happen
jeezech has showed his [ __ ] dick
magic what happens this [ __ ] does go
both ways though like none of us know
who the [ __ ] the firefighters are for
this city right but when they do a
firefighter calendar I know exactly all
of a sudden hey you're Mr descent is
that Franco or is that [ __ ] Romy
do you think this leaked uh you know
like in a modern day teen movie like
those frat comedies I feel like this
plot would be funny if it leaked because
they were airdropping each other and
then the boys Locker Room's one wall
away and then all their phones go off
they go
now like uh hypothetically if it was you
because you're a wasconian is that how
you say it by the way no obviously not
what's the word for Wisconsin whiskey I
just I like that one
tonight oh really it's like Samsonite
it's kind of tight yeah that sounds cool
Wisconsin sounds like a rock okay
anyways no one ever calls themselves
that uh you're from sconce uh I'm sure
that if you were in that photo and then
it got leaked you'd be like oh [ __ ]
right like that would suck like there'd
be like a lot of dignity that just got
like ripped away from you right but then
not if you got the good titties yeah
maybe that could Kickstart My only fans
career that's true you know I'm not
thinking from the good titty sidebar
that's the title of the video talk about
the bad titties yeah so we want to
assume the worst let's say you got the
smallest titties in that group right
this is it's not about the size yeah
it's not about the size that's true it's
about the niceness sometimes small
but then you go into the next game and
it's [ __ ] sold out like are you like
worth it or where are you at with this
you know yeah I mean are they kicked off
the team are they just like oh let's
just keep going they're selling out
[ __ ] their tickets right now and
that's fine obviously that's gonna
affect them for you know other stuff but
book more photos we're talking about
like mental health inside I don't think
I don't think they're gonna be like oh
you can't work here anymore because your
titty like got leaked when you're in
college that's a 1999 problem but what's
the what's the crime scene investigation
what's going on with this I guess yeah
probably one of the girls so the person
that makes it in trouble yeah said the
unauthorized sharing is a significant
and wrongful Invasion or she gave it to
her boyfriend and the boyfriend gave it
to his friend and then that's what
happened yeah if I had an eight inch
dick I'd be leaking pictures
[Laughter]
oh I re-leaked it you're so clumsy
[Music]